- What's the art in
the art of programming?
Why, why's there, of the
few words in the title,
why is art one of them?
- Yeah, well, that's what I
wrote my Turing lecture about,
and so when people talk about art,
I mean, what the word means is,
something that's not in nature.
So, when you have artificial intelligence,
the art comes from the same root,
saying this is something that
was created by human beings,
and then it's gotten further meaning
often of fine art, which
adds this beauty to this mix,
and so then we have things
that are artistically done
and this means not only done by humans
but also done in a way that's elegant and
brings joy and, and has,
I guess, Tolstoy versus Dostoyevsky.
- (laughs) Right.
- Going, but anyway,
it's that part that says
that it's done well,
as well as not only different from nature.
In general then, art is
what human beings are
specifically good at,
and when they say artificial intelligence,
well, they're trying
to mimic human beings.
- But there's an element
of fine art and beauty,
you are one cool--
- That's what I,
that's what I try to also say that,
you can write a program
and make a work of art.